The nICE mug invented by Glenn Auerbach lets
you drink your beverage out of a mug made
of ice.
And an inventor in Portland has created a
new type of mattress specially designed for
the perfect night of cuddling.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.... this is Mind Blow
Engineers at Stanford University have invented
a microbial battery to create electricity
from poop.
The prototype is the size of a D-battery and
uses naturally-occurring wired microbes that
produce electricity as they digest plant and
animal waste.
And they hope that one day they can use a
similar system on a large scale in sewage
treatment plants to create great amounts of
electricity.
Researchers at IK4-CIDETEC have made a polymer
that has the ability to repair itself.
They cut the material in half and without
the need of any catalyst or stimulus, it fully
recovered its mechanical properties after
simply being left for two hours at room temperature.
The applications for this discovery can help
in industrial applications, electrical and
automotive sectors, various construction,
and developing biomaterials.
Pioneer has created a new AR-HUD navigation
system that superimposes information onto
the windshield.
It gives the driver the ability to see navigation
and other important information right in front
of them without having to take their eyes
off the road.
It uses a laser and a concave half mirror
to project the image.
It even includes information like parking
and restaurants that are nearby so you don't
have to distracted looking for anything.
I'm just a bird.
Layin' on another bird.
"Just Mayo" and "Beyond eggs" are new products
looking to replace eggs with plants.
The makers claim the plant-based artificial
eggs do a great job with baking cakes and
making mayonnaise but have yet to master scrambled
eggs.
YOBOT is a robot that's solving luggage management
problems at a hotel called Yotel, in New York
City.
With the push of a button guests can have
their luggage sent to nearby airports.
You simply choose your airport and your terminal
and Yobot will send it there before you get
there.
They're currently looking into creating an
app that let's you track your luggage on its
way and in the future they hope to create
a way to not only send luggage but also people
to their airport destinations.
So yeah.
The MINIR is a minimally invasive neurosurgical
intracranial robot.
Created at the Maryland Robotics Center, the
idea is that this little robot could suck
out cancerous tissue from the human brain.
And it's special because it can be used while
the person is undergoing an MRI.
Since the MRI maps the tumor in real time
even as it shifts during surgery the robot
will be able to effectively remove all the
cancerous tissue.
Charalampos Loannou of Greece created this
movement enhancing glove for the Google science
fair.
The idea came to him when he saw his grandmother
having difficulty picking up the TV remote
due to a lack of mobility in her hands.
It has pressure sensors and motors that can
adjust the strength to the object being grasped.
He created the glove so the wearer can gain
back the strength to do every day tasks like
picking up objects.
Boeing's Unmanned Little Bird is the first
full-size autonomous helicopter.
And it even has the ability to land itself.
The sensor in the helicopter maps the terrain,
plans routes, checks for a landing site's
safety, and avoids obstacles.
Most auto pilot programs that are used now
are only for cruising and all of the decision
making is still left to the human controlling
the aircraft.
It's a first for robotic aviation and since
the job of a medevac pilot is extremely dangerous
- they hope that this will save the lives
of pilots in the future.
Finally, if you haven't seen this yet it's
an incredible video called Box from Bot And
Dolly that uses projection-mapping on moving
objects...
I'm gonna leave you with a guy hitting an
egg in mid air with a boomerang and then catching
it.
And as always - thanks for watching!